[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey
[Applause]
hello
look at this
what a well-behaved audience
nobody stood yeah
you won't get in trouble you could stand
yes
[Applause]
put your boobs away put your boobs away
now as a matter of fact we'll take care
of the sitting you guys stand for the
whole episode yes
let's do that oh we did it
first one
first one
yes
in the sand royersford um give
yourselves a round of applause for being
in royersford pennsylvania
i wouldn't have it any other way doing
the first hey babe here in royersford pa
saul joel's comedy dome yeah who is from
local who's from royersford
wow
good people i didn't realize we had such
a white fan base um
is there a single
single person of color here that you are
you're the whitest person here yes
thank you thank you
thank you thank you it was almost a
problem
we got one holy smokes thank you so much
and thank you for sitting all the way up
running nothing against all of you why
did you raise your hand when we asked if
there was any people of color here
no i said people of color saying that
she's singing single oh she's saying
she's anyone's single here she's letting
us know oh
yes thank you so much thank you i love
it oh my god you are so fashionable like
fashionable yeah do you have a shawl
that matches your top i love it stand up
again
what is that wow wow
oh man
we should have dressed like that what a
good looking guy pulling off a man bun
like nobody else can i got news for you
it's beautiful beautiful glasses i don't
think they're prescription though you
know who oh there's black black people
can pull off
man this is going to be good by the way
get your phones out let's get ready
it's impossible for a black man to not
look good in a fedora that's a fact
that's a fact three people who could
wear fedoras three types of people black
people children and justin timberlake
and that's it
and and then you just prove to me that
you pull off a man bun like if i had a
man bun
no good no well you almost did i mean
you had this is the first time you've
trimmed your hair i know but i can't put
it up in a bun because i'm not spelt let
me i put my hair up in a bun i look like
a
donut with a ponytail so let me ask you
a question right now what is the
temperature of your scalp because it is
a million degrees out and you have got a
lot of hair i would guess your scalp is
over 100 degrees right now oh it's like
kelvin it's
this is crazy i hope you i'm gonna just
hose you down like this is like this is
like a lollapalooza yeah is that anyone
feeling faint i i'm gonna think she's
gonna stay hydrated i know i love that
too what a classy venue bring your own
beers and chairs what a great sit in the
sand
oh yeah we'll come but you got to bring
your own seats
are you okay we got we got man buns up
on the screen i feel like
something's missing now yeah from the
show what's missing what do we always
have
well
oh pillows we need pillows
we need pillows
there you go should we sit down with the
pillows
oh yeah well you'll see it honey yeah if
the corners present a problem for me
rest assured they will be turned in
listen yeah salsa i need you to tell me
what to do with my head
sal's mental health has not taken the
day off so all right okay here we go ah
now it feels good
i'll see you guys in an hour how are you
doing
wow i've never sat down to perform for
400 people before i know but because
listen most of the time when we do the
the show yeah we kind of just sit down
and we start talking and um that's what
we're going to attempt to do today
except the difference is there's 400
people here so
you know
400 you know beautiful people somebody
has a sign up i won't read what it says
oh i can't see it i can't see it
oh
shout out tom brady listen listen listen
listen let's
let me get up
let's get some rules straight up top
we don't need the assist on the tom
brady
you think that's not drilled into our
heads i drove here for two hours being
like don't get tom brady yeah don't
forget tom brady and what kind of paper
did you write that in it looks like a
sandwich bag
what is that
you know
now i guess now's as good a time as ever
to just give a shout out to tom brady
and tom brady and the bucks look here's
what happened they won the super bowl
this year in tampa which has never
happened before the man's 43 years old
he's the oldest guy in the nfl yeah
somehow he pulls it off i'd be remiss to
not mention how proud i am of patrick
mahomes though of the kansas city chiefs
what a good-looking guy and a star in
his own right he'll be back next year
they got a good team they got a bright
future what else is missing from this
damn show
oh
possibly
the homeless pip where's the homeless
peppy where you at
reveal yourself
there's a pep
that's what he looks like
look at him look at him go
look at his corduroy shorts
look at him
95 degrees thick corduroys
that's it same outfit every day he's
like a cartoon character he wears those
glasses in my home yes for the whole
show
you really commit you do i love like
part of your identity
now can you please go back there thank
you
thank you homeless pimp love the
homeless pimp everybody the best
so
yeah what's up babe i closed on a house
today i got a house today whoa
i got a house really not a house
i have no money so please buy the
t-shirts yeah we need to merch did you
feel
like uh look at this the leg cross you
don't get that much by the way
the pillows are wet pimp by the way and
they're sticky so i don't know what's
going on
did you feel like um
a chapter of your life did you feel like
a benchmark like when you drove away
from the closing do you feel more adult
today i do
here's what i did is i said i'm trying
to you know uh get get myself back in
shape and back on my fitness pal i did
the um i closed on the house obviously
you know put down almost all the money i
have to to get into the house i said you
know what i feel good um i don't want to
eat bad i'm trying to watch what i wait
but i went off highland boulevard on
staten island i went to the tim hortons
and i ate about 3 000 calories of bacon
egg and cheese croissants donuts iced
coffee with no milk because that's got
too many calories
[Laughter]
oh you just carbo-loaded right at the
closing i did and i've told you
backstage that i don't feel good and i
and i was like what's going on do i have
covet and then i just remembered that i
ate tim hortons you have horton you have
you have horton 19. i got well i got
hurt in 21. yeah 21. i got 21. i am an
emotional leader too yeah shout out
emotional leaders
shout them out
shout out emotions
shout them all out how many how many
people here are emotional eaters
what does it make you feel better what's
the last sir sir in the hat with the
glasses what's the last thing you ate
emotionally screaming out yes the guy
with the beard the guy who the only
person who's got sunglasses on his head
yeah yes you sir screaming out what'd
you emotionally eat recently
donuts what kind no he didn't say donuts
he said donuts yeah we were talking to
the guy with the glasses but it's okay
it's a big crowd and we all want to
contribute
you ate donuts what was your last
emotional
oh my god excuse us sorry fatty
yeah
excuse us for driving
at a place that's not even on a map yeah
jesus christ
for the eighth time my god the direction
we're doing comedy in a sandbox you
don't gotta get upset
your attitude over here your attitude
certainly doesn't match your delightful
smile jesus
okay i won't bring up cheetos anymore
for the eighth time that's gonna i'm
gonna make that a t-shirt cheetos for
the eighth time
that's the merch for tomorrow shows
i hope you don't find this insulting but
a little bit a part of me inside
secretly wishes you never have a [ __ ]
cheeto again
yeah
yeah that's what you can do when you
insult someone yeah just sip through a
heart silly straw right after it really
softens the blow
like what are you doing here you piece
of [ __ ]
you're not really a piece of [ __ ] i just
illustrated you you're not no you're not
you have good positive and sh she is a
piece of [ __ ] well if your friend's
saying your pc you're sorry what's your
name
wrong emily it's piece of [ __ ] yeah i
gotta be honest emily the percentage of
emilies that are pieces of [ __ ] are high
why do you say that just to be part of
the joke or are you really a piece of
[ __ ] cause you don't
self-deprecating humor that's a good
piece of [ __ ] that makes you a funny you
should get into comedy then we all
self-deprecate yeah
what's up got big news we got september
17th and 18th fort lauderdale i'm coming
september 24th to the 26th irvine improv
los angeles area almost sold out the
first show on october 23rd at fox woods
is sold out only tickets available for
the second show and big big news we got
the wilbur theater in boston on sale
right now november 21st laugh boston
november 18 to the 20th all sold out
wilbur theater we've added sunday night
christy comedy.com november 21st thank
you so much i love you all right cute
kids come see me in austin september
24th at the paramount theater that's for
the moon tower comedy festival uh i will
be headlining there and then the next
day september 25th i will be in denver
at the bellco theater with david spade
and frank caliendo for charity uh all
tickets to salvocanocomedy.com and then
i'm on tour with the guys this tour has
started it's an arena tour i'll tell you
the first weekend uh glendale arizona
san diego california and sacramento
california those are the first big dates
but all dates are up and they're at the
tenderloins.com
tour but this is what it's this is what
it is we're not gonna you know we're
gonna play with you guys but you're
gonna come along for the ride this is a
podcast like any other day as a matter
of fact
these shows will be
next week's podcast you're gonna be part
of the podcast
yeah part of the podcast by the way
speaking of chubb you know what i ate
you know i was just in i was just in
philadelphia great city i was just
thank you to the people that came out to
the philly punch line i appreciate it um
um
um we ate
how about this joe derosa from the taste
buds podcast
family friend tells me calls me in
homeless pimp he says hey he goes you
know you're in philly you know what you
should do eat a philly taco i said okay
where where's the best place to get it
he goes no you got to make it i said
what are you talking about he goes what
a philly taco is is you go to jim's
cheese steaks
right and then right across the street
you go to lorenzo's pizza which has
these humongous pizza slices and you
wrap the cheese steak oh my god in the
pizza slice how emotional are you
exactly i said joe are you depressed so
he said that's that's a true
philadelphia person have you guys heard
of that
okay so they've heard of it is it only
at that location like they have a little
thing or it's anywhere
so you're supposed to go to gyms you
have to get yourself lorenzo's because
lorenzo's is the big slice okay the
cheesesteak place the line for gyms was
insane like down the block nuts insane
you would have thought they were giving
away the johnson and johnson and and i
said and i said the line is too long
here so i went to this place called
ishka bibbles which sounds like my
daughter made up a name of a cheesesteak
place yeah but it was so excitable
sounds like a children's clothing line
ishke bibbles yeah yeah my daughter's in
she only wears ishgar bibble what do you
want to get ask me get my daughter for
christmas what do you want to get hey
what are you getting any daughter for
christmas ichika bibbles oh yeah excuse
me hat shirts dance um so i wrapped an
ishgabible cheesesteak which just made
the ishmaels i went to which is and
listen was very good i'm telling you
it's very good but it's 100 asian owned
and operated cheese take place which is
what's funny to me because normally when
you get a cheesesteak from philly it's
like you know some fat balding italian
guy that's like you know what is it
whizz wit with onions right but instead
it was a small chinese woman going what
is it where is it
steak i rashed the wrapped ishgabible
cheesesteak which apparently is a
violation in the lorenzo slice eat it i
said i ate half of it homeless pimp has
video evidence i ate more like 85 of it
but then i ate it to be like oh now i'm
a proud philadelphian call de rosa
proudly i say hey joe i just ate the
philly taco
how many times have you done this he
goes never i would never do that
why did you do that i was like you
mother
so now i ate the 9 000 calories and i
feel like a bloated piece of [ __ ] three
weeks later and joe is running around
with no shoulders talking about
cheesecake
yeah he sent you on the wild goose is
was um are you guys from like the philly
in the philly area is it really like
there's cheesesteaks that are better
than others or it's just the one that
you it's just the one yeah but all of
you here that are screaming yes all have
different opinions right so it's all
[ __ ] kind of right i mean you could
get a philly cheesesteak in new york
that's just as good as any place in
philly yes or no yes
you south jersey
she said south jersey but the woman with
the white shirt right here next to the
man in the coast guard thank you for
your service is saying she also likes
ishq bibbles now is your name trish
what's your name
jenny that's the same as trish it's the
same thing those are interchangeable
names you like ishgabibles see somebody
likes issue bibles i'm not the only one
but
but it's bread meat and cheese right
what what is the secret thing that's
happening at your favorite spot that's
not happening at the one across the
street what is south jersey i'll wait
she's got to make the meat right
and the cheese and the roll
what do you think is it
it's the good with the bread it's all
about the bread
and the cheese so you can't be that
person that eats a cheesesteak and asked
for to have it in a lettuce wrap
you'll get killed for that
what's your opinion on whiz in the
sandwich
is that a sacrilege
but gino's is an institution and they do
it like oh my uh but sal here's what i
heard
genos and pats right are the ones right
across stream from each other that's
like i like the jets and the sharks yes
yeah i was told by the a person in
philly that that's like going to like
times square that's like being a hack
and a tourist okay regular philly people
would not go there they say that they
use it's all imitation [ __ ] it's not
okay that's what i was is that true i
was told jim's
i was told jim's also his hack that you
got to go to tony luke's or places in
south jersey all right
they're saying sandros is there plastic
and cheese whiz there's pl
palmer's paper saying plastic can be
made of long chains consisting of small
molecules like proteins this concept can
be applied to cheese whiz so if you just
consider natural plastics cheese whiz is
indeed only one step away from plastic
there you go
holy [ __ ] this is from anybody from
really far who's from way far from
pennsylvania where are you from
you drove in from south carolina no you
uh
oh my god you did this is awkward we
have a show in south carolina thursday
thursday
we're going to be
yeah
so south carolina where are you guys
from
arizona you drove here no you didn't you
flew no just for the show no you didn't
you booked passage
from arizona to royesford solely to come
to this podcast show
please he's showing us his license
no i know you're from arizona
but oh wow handsome prove it
what are you doing
take care of it
uh no wait wait but you didn't come here
i know you're from arizona but you
didn't come here you didn't take your
flight
it was an unfortunate chain of events he
said
oh fortunately i thought you said
unfortunate oh terrific
okay what goes on in arizona oh so you
right now you feel like this is like the
winter for you here you're cooling off
here yeah
you're in jeans
you're like oh it's
christmas is coming
so you got arizona we got south carolina
where okay with this guy you got to be
from california look at your hair stand
up tell us
where
[ __ ] friends
nice wow
shout out to pink panther what a
handsome [ __ ] guy that's also from
france france only sends their best
friend
france yeah wow wow and you flew from
france just for the podcast
yeah yeah bonjour babe
what's everything you know about france
right now you do you know history though
okay
no i i don't know much here's what i
know about i know i love you
france i know you know paris but they
say paris um i know um french fries i
know the pink panther croissants
um i know tony parker
sure sure um i know the french
revolution
yeah um
you said traitor
you know what i said the other day i i
don't know what context i said it but i
said oh
i think they french kissed and i said
who the [ __ ] have i become
who talks like that who's this who calls
a kiss an open mouth kiss a friend i
haven't called it a french kiss since
i'm like 11. french kissing during the
pandemics the death sentence you don't
want a french kiss
you don't want to do that did you guys
invent that kiss why is it a french kiss
you guys have ownership of that
how excited and and the woman you're
with you are not from france
you offer well both of you for because i
just that would be funny if you're from
royersford and you're like my
boyfriend's from france they were like
get the fatty hat
she she courts them all over town what
are the similarities between paris and
royersford sir
do they also have a denny's
what are the similarities between paris
and royesford probably two black people
um pip says until recently it was
illegal for women to wear trousers in
france yeah can you speak to that sir
is it illegal you can wear trousers
there what are trousers are they
underwear what is trousers oh yeah they
ants
they're just pants so why can't you just
call them pants
they're slacks
whoa go back go back we gotta get
trousers go back one pimp did you see
those pants that second photo there
all right how about we wear those next
episode
i'm down for that
could you imagine i mean you know it's
you ever go into a retail store i have a
gripe with retail
clothing you walk in and and brands that
sell to both men and women men have like
a rack
and women are like 97 percent of the
store and it's because of options like
this yeah we can't get that whoa go back
another one look at those other pants on
the right there that's nice option sweet
jesus are those really pants anymore i'd
like you to wear those pants just to see
the jaden smith tattoos face just
plowing just to watch his face sticking
through
those would show both jaden's off
effortlessly that that would showcase
him nice yeah
this lady wants you to take take your
pants off no
no that's for the that's for the
wednesday show
that's the surprise guest
[Laughter]
so yeah we got it yeah
we have a guest uh can we say who the
guest is for wednesday because it
doesn't affect anything right what's her
name though
we should look it up
you
the girl with the biggest mouth
[Applause]
and and you're gonna be able you're
gonna be able if you come to the show
tomorrow put things in her mouth yeah
and here's how we're ending the show
tomorrow
she's putting the whole dome in her
mouth yes
that back there right there it's going
to look like you're going into moby dick
her whole upper tooth area is going to
be that and then the tongue is going to
be on the floor and at the end of the
show we're just going to run into her
and just see what happens so that's
going to be the guest tomorrow and um
and it's going to be great and maybe one
more special guest if we if we could
swing it correct we tried to get kane
tanaka we really did
but they said that he would literally
break if he flew across the ocean yeah
she is it a guy or a girl i forgot no
isn't it a woman it's a woman she would
break it out told us i think that we've
been pronouncing her name wrong have we
been have we been culturally
appropriating kate tanaka's name uh i
thought it was kane but someone was like
that's not how you say it
how many of you guys think you'll
outlive kane tanaka
no when she was 107 which is years ago
at the age of 90 she took care of her
cataracts but you see what what our show
is is something like this comes up like
we we had no plan in talking about her
when it popped up and now she's a legend
uh she doesn't even know what a big deal
she's becoming roy's for pennsylvania
she's never heard of us right she
doesn't know hey i would no
i mean when she passes and please i hope
she lives to 200 but when she passes
get ready for a very special episode
that's a very special episode the
funeral of kane tanaka along with my
fish along with the fish i say we do it
i say we don't do the fish funeral until
until we do it for kane yeah i'd say so
because how can you do how can you
which is more important you can't pick
yeah i can't pick
somebody said the fish is more important
to be fair my fish has been dead for
eight years already though
right still in my freezer right now well
so we got i mean south carol i i don't
think anybody can beat france does there
anybody think that they're further away
from france
nobody okay because i was gonna say
that'd be insane that'd actually be
illegal then you'd be in that you're not
supposed to be here this guy thinks
where are you from
where
new jersey turkey
oh turkey i think you said jersey i was
like i'll do the jokes [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but turkey the country of turkey is that
geographically further than france it
has to be right it's further yeah it's
it is it's further west and i don't know
much about geography but i know that no
further is it east or west i'm sorry
east
you don't know it much no but it's
western
isn't that western
when you go far enough we're talking
about i mean it's a circle so eventually
east is west well it's not a circle it's
flat um
wow three interesting facts about turkey
ready for this let's see if you know
this sir
um
where are you from are you from istanbul
why do you have you don't have a turkish
accent
are you hiding it are you working
undercover for the turkish government
do they have a problem with the hay bay
podcast in istanbul
wow
but yeah but it's also famous for its
carpets that's a little
you know it's racist
i mean you know what i mean turkish
carpets and bazaars
i don't know what a bizarre i miss a
bizarre i love it when's the last time
you've been with bizarre it's been years
and i just had this conversation with
who i mean
oh okay yeah i'll ask you again you
cheating on me yeah yeah yeah no but i
was like i missed those bazaars and
those street like those festivals like i
went to catholic grammar school
and they used to have like bingo nights
and like casino nights and then once a
year we would have this local fair
and you know they bring in the like you
play those carnival games and yeah right
you know you shoot into a clown's mouth
blowing up a balloon you know trying to
win a stuffed banana and things like
that i miss that you're doing a
scrambler and stuff like that just like
some real easy entertainment like blow
70 bucks just trying to win a pair of
fuzzy dice or something i was on out of
bizarre saint matthias school ridgewood
queens 94
5. i was on the ferris wheel because
they used to make the you know used to
make the rides like whatever and the
ferris wheel you know had like the latch
thing and you know
i i was on a ferris wheel that cell
hand to god i got stuck on the ferris
wheel at the very top by myself at nine
ten years old my mother waited oh my god
she let me go around once alone right
big boy stuff and it got stuck like
fully got stuck yeah so somebody had to
climb up then they
maneuvered some stuff up there i guess
whatever the problem was was stuck up
there and then i finally came down but
dude i was stuck at the top of where
same with that metaphor for your life
baby
stuck at the top
slowly coming down
slowly coming down now your mom will
just find a way to drag you down again
that's what it is
uh it seems to me that ferris wheels in
general seem to get stuck more than we
would all appreciate what scares you
more let me ask you this yeah are you
scared of what would you do first
would you go skydiving first or go on a
hot air balloon
i've been skydiving once i'll never do
it again i feel like i did it and now
i'm playing with it's like final destiny
why would you never do it again
because it's tough to have a good photo
when the sky dies no everybody looks
different oh my god his face looks like
the rate at which the wind blows into my
body made any excess skin on my neck and
cheek blowed out like a [ __ ] blowfish
and i got the video so like the guy
jumps ahead of me with like a handicam
and then he's just free falling and just
taping me come down and he put it on dvd
and i got home and this was 2006 in new
pawls and i got home and i threw the dvd
and shout out new pulse shout out
skydiving shout out 2006.
i'm sorry for 2004 ruben stutter yeah
and what i'm sorry for 2004. i'm sorry
for
2004. come on you know that song ruben
stutter uh american idol ruben stutter
the velvet teddy bear i'm sorry for
2004. i never heard it yeah i'm sorry
for 2004. what the [ __ ] in 2004.
what did he do in 2004 there were things
that went on in 2004. he's sorry for
2004. he said he's sorry for 2004 nobody
to this day it's remained a mystery how
many people know that song by round of
applause
not many
not many i'm sorry for 2004.
what is it what is his issue can we play
it pimple we'll use a one-hit wonder
because no i love her i voted for him
also did i yeah i used to vote i used to
vote hardcore
you'd call up on a landline yeah i used
to vote 100 i'd say i voted i voted for
him you know who i voted for i voted for
taylor hicks and i also voted for bo
bice remember that i voted for taylor
i voted for the mick chicken kid the who
what was the kid not mcchicken what was
his name oh yeah the the the chicken
little chicken little chicken little
[Laughter]
i started i started i used to vote like
the first four seasons i used to call
the hotline yeah and vote and i was i
was invested yeah i don't watch it
anymore taylor hicks wow that guy had
gray hair when he was 18 years old full
gray yeah which is a bold move i don't
mind well he didn't choose
no but you could dye it yeah like if you
want full gray right now i think it'd be
all right
i don't know i think i would look kind
of weird my god my dad didn't go grey
till his late 60s so i'm really holding
out but he did go bald on his legs young
and so did i yeah i'm 100 i have 100
ball of legs me too but i'll take the
ball length
in order to keep my hair i've never had
an ounce of hair on my legs ever yeah
and you have ball eyeballed legs and
arms yeah yeah that's what it is and i
have like three sprouts to chest hair
shout out bald legs i don't have that
much chest there either yeah yeah well
like two hairless cats i know
i like not having a lot of hair i don't
mind it yeah i don't miss it
gets in the way
speaking of bald
i'd like to take a moment yeah we'd like
we'd like to take a moment
to talk to you about keith keeps
[Applause]
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35.
more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male pattern ballistics you
can't skip this mother
[Applause]
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
keeps offers a simple stress free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home
low cost
treatment start at just 10
per month and keeps offers generic
versions
discreet packaging and proven results
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss
go to k
[Applause]
bring in the next ad read
we only have five more no
we were like should we do ed reads would
that be funny well like let's do one
it'll be funny we'll do one live one
we're like oh let's read it
simultaneously they got a kick out of
that we read your comments here's a
problematic headline for us getting one
hot dog takes 35 minutes off life so how
many minutes off life are we at
thousands yeah
but anyway we're like let's do it when
we start talking in unison they'll
remember how we did it on the other one
they'll go bat [ __ ] and cheer through
the whole thing it'll be awesome
well we all know how it actually turned
out
let's just say if you come to the show
next the ad reads will be getting
cut hot dogs take 35 minutes off i read
peanut butter i read the same article
they said peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches add like 15 minutes are you
serious i swear to god i don't know what
are you am i so we're heading out to
we'll die when we die so if you eat a
hot dog eat two pb j's right after you
golden
you eat a hot dog with pb and j why the
hell not remember pizza buffets have the
peanut butter and jelly pizza never in
my entire life i would have bet you a
million dollars that stuff doesn't exist
who's been
does anybody remember the pizza buffet
that the peanut butter jelly pizza thank
you fellow white trash i appreciate it
oh my god yes no that can't be real that
can't be real it was in the pizza buffet
only the pizza buffet on in nassau
county long island well they had them
all over but the pizza cafe in nashville
county long island went rogue and
started offering
peanut butter and jam on that pizza
where was the buffet you got the peanut
butter and jelly pizza are from
eerie pennsylvania and you remember it
thoroughly and they don't have it
anymore and it's not causa covered they
cut it way before coven unbelievable
question is the pizza the crust and then
just peanut butter and jelly so you're
basically eating a sandwich or did with
this sauce and cheese
i don't remember if there was sauce to
nuts
oh so they just got cute it's not really
a pizza you ate a peanut butter and
jelly on bread yeah i would love to try
the peanut butter and jelly on the sauce
and cheese pizza and then see what
what's the weirdest thing
i would do it let's see if see who see
who pukes first what's the weirdest
thing you've ever ate while you like
were high on on marijuana well i mean i
don't really get high
that much i will say what i do what i
did do for a long time is you know
yogurts yelp like the cookie crunch
yogurts you know like they would have
the top oh yeah like like the top has
the like the treats yeah you dump it in
and you mix it up i used to put i used
to eat
turkey cheese
lettuce mayo
on a lender's bagel with cookie crunch
on top my mother would give that to me
for lunch i swear to god she would give
it to me for lunch and the the she
allowed you to have that it's what i
would eat
what how is that what you're saying yeah
that's what i would eat yeah but i said
she would allow you to have that and you
said that's what i would eat like she
had no choice in the matter
well it's either that i wasn't eating
you know what i mean are you serious you
took that heart of a stance you said put
cookie crumbles on my turkey or i will
go on a starvation diet i'll tell you
what happened one time one time they ran
my mom ran out of the cookie crunch
yogurts and instead she put the eminem
top on because he used to have the m m
ones on the turkey sandwich i wouldn't
eat it i said what kind of psychopath
puts eminem toppings on a turkey cheese
lendis bagel sandwich it's cookie crunch
or nothing wow that's wild
i dip i've known to dip my cookies you
know i love dunking dunking cookies uh
anybody else
[Applause]
what kind of psycho are you
i can't uh have a cookie without dunking
a cookie so i dunk in anything that's
available
that sounds worse than it is
i've jumped in i was going to start
around these things that are available
yeah no i've dunked like my my my
chocolate chip cookies in like theraflu
in water water iced
yeah that's very interesting it's hot
yeah yeah i get it but yeah and it kind
of actually that's a good way if you
don't like medicine why don't parents do
that like when i was didn't want to take
my medicine as a kid unless it was
bubble gum flavored why not just put the
bob why not just put the medicine that's
icky on a cookie and i'll eat the cookie
with the medicine on it parents don't
think of that yeah i'm a parent yeah do
you do that with your kids well she's
not sick right now i don't think but
but next time she's sick then you're
just gonna shove her penicillin into
like a slice of cheese put it right on a
butterfinger and say eat that
how do you um like with with your with
your daughter
how do you
what kind of an eater is she do you have
does she ever battle you at this young
age already with like oh yeah does she
ever put a foot down and be like i'm
eating cookies on my sandwich or i'm
eating nothing she'll well for her it's
about nutella if we say if she has ha
i'm telling you
if we say delilah no more nutella she
throws a hunger strike like she's gandhi
she will not
she will not there was one time when she
didn't eat for like 40 hours she just
wouldn't eat and i'm like what am i
gonna do forced her down the you know
she was like drinking water she would
not eat anything we put we were
screaming at her take everything away
we'll throw the american girl dolls away
we'll throw everything away she did not
care and then she said not until i have
nutella so i like that you were using
terrorist tactics against your daughter
yeah like we will kill all the american
girl dogs oh yeah no we start we yeah
you you leave her a video on like her on
her little like tablet it's you in like
a hood being like attention delilah yeah
we will kill all of your american girl
dolls i had a butcher knife to graham
i said i'll do it right now who is this
pimp who are you pulling a republican
sound alarm on damn democrats amnesty
push this got hey babe written all over
it yeah this is what we talk about let's
go you wanted to do the next 25 minutes
on kabal
[Laughter]
we want to take a minute to talk to you
about amnesty
i don't even know what amnesty is what
is that oh it's international i know
that it's international yeah isn't that
when you like like try to get people out
of like a safe haven is it like when you
i was in amnesty i think i was in the
amnesty international club in high
school right and like we wrote letters
to prisoners
like to keep them company or something i
don't know right if you like it then you
should have put a ring on it if you like
it
to the left to the left
[Laughter]
i like to be a man and i like a band
listen to me yes you know you get so
stressed out when you're looking for a
ring especially a wedding ring as a guy
manly bands
makes it easy you found a gal you found
a partner that you love you don't want
to go to the store and be caught up with
all that you go into the jewelry store
it's like the wild west you don't know
what you're buying you don't know what
the hell you're buying i don't know what
they'll do i'm getting ripped off
you sign up for manly band they said
your ring size they're at home you size
up your ring you can get a ring made out
of gold silver steel wood meteorites yes
whatever you need a sore bone dinosaur
bone
and that manly ring sizer is good just
in case you know you you know you order
a ring and then all of a sudden your
fingers get fat getting too much salt
you got the melee band ring sizer boom
you can size exactly to what your ring
is whether you're fat or skinny fans
offers free shipping worldwide yeah
you could be in the sahara right now and
get a meteorite manly band delivered to
you to die
while there might be a 50 chance of your
marriage working out there's a 100
chance that you're going to love your
ban 30-day exchange policy and a free
warranty to order your manly ban and get
21
they give 21. manly bands making moves
baby plus a free silicone ring go to
manlybands.com
hey babe that's manly
dot com slash hey babe for 21 off manly
bands the best damn rings period
and the sentence i don't know right
anyway am i saying that right
for people have been convicted of
political offenses amnesty for political
prisoners oh wow i didn't think they
were political
why you ever been to jail three times
seriously no
not once for anything no
never even been handcuffed holding cell
what'd you do yeah what'd you do in the
whole
yeah a little tiff what happened nothing
okay mix it up actually savile count is
not even my real identity what is it i
mean i'm in witness protection this is
i'm wit pro
imagine that
interesting no i don't know i mean not
really i've never done anything too bad
never done anything yeah i think um what
you have have you
a couple of times been arrested oh
graffiti graffiti graffiti graffiti wait
you're graffiti you what did you you you
know how to tag
no but i still did graffiti oh you just
drew like a dick on a wall no not like
your name and like beautiful colors and
spray my tag my tag name was sk
s-k-e
ske stood for sickest kid ever oh [ __ ]
oh my god and one time i was about 16
years old and i tagged up i wrote sk
on a mailbox okay and there was a a cop
in the neighborhood who used to speak to
the kids at school his name was officer
bill
and he ran this program called specta
which stood for something like something
with drug stuff and he was the patrolman
on duty and saw me with his own eyes
where i'd scare on the mailbox and
arrested me
told i swear to god arrested me like as
if i wasn't in his inspector program in
his class five years ago arrested me and
told me that i was going to get 10 years
in prison for
desecrating
federal property and then he showed me i
beat i was in handcuffs at you know
whatever i was seven i forgot how old i
was maybe 17.
handcuffs you know no cell phone
anything like that back then took me to
the precinct the 104th precinct in
queens sat me down with my hands cuffed
behind my back and pulled up on the
screen penalties for desecrating federal
property and it said 10 years yourself
and he put me in a holding cell
by myself called my mother
comes back in literally 25 minutes later
lets me out of prison at that point
though you could still use skay i could
yeah because he's like saddest kid ever
sick it's right saddest kid ever shitty
yeah scared scared his kid ever yeah so
i and then 25 minutes later
they undo the cuffs my mother comes and
gets me she yells at me i say mom i'm
hungry
before you know it you're eating cookies
on turkey exactly you you you um you
came up with skay on your own how old
are you
so i would love to have been there like
a fly on the wall when you thought of it
you were like
yes
this is gonna dominate
yeah sickest kid ever so my two options
my two ones that i that i struggled with
was was what the one we landed on was sk
sickest kid ever and then also we ca i
was i used to tag up pen cause i would
say the kid got ink
why
i don't know what does that mean
i don't know but i was a kid
yeah how many times do you think you
wrote sk
like hundreds
ah 50.
and just did you just write with a
marker ske or did you do a design i was
pure under peer pressure the point of
graffiti you know is like street art
it's not to vandalize so
the fumes from this spray paint would
give me sometimes an allergic reaction
so a lot of times
so a lot of times i would either write i
either had a marker there's been a
couple of times where i swear to god i
wrote sk on the wall of the building
with a number two pencil
because that's all i had and i just
slightly did it and then we would run
away oh god that's what it is gay i
don't remember i remember so i used to
run a bar right and there was um
there was a kid that was known on staten
island for graffitiing his tag name and
everyone knew the name because he wrote
it everywhere and it was very peculiar
the name that he would write everywhere
kind of weird disgusting doesn't make
sense was
vaginal
swear to god he'd write vag anal he
wrote it thousands of there are places
in staten island right now 20 years
later that say vagina
he was a local celebrity nobody knew he
was like our banksy
right
and one time one time i'm bartending one
night and a kid walks out of the
bathroom which is the left end of the
bar and somebody else walks in and they
kick the door open his mother friend
they go sal come here and i run and he
goes was that there earlier and i go no
and he goes
that's vaginal
and we
flipped out well i go and he walked out
and he was hanging out outside the bar
and i got on the phone i'm like get down
here right now we got vaginal we have
him dead to right you almost made his
citizens arrested i should have went
into the shadows
[Applause]
i'm the guy who got vageno
yes and then years later i got vaginatal
again
yes
we
i'm like we walked outside like five us
and we just caught him we said excuse me
come here and he was like he knew it and
we walked him into the bathroom and i
pointed at it and i go did you do that
are you vaginal
and he goes yeah i did it and i kind of
knew the kid peripherally and everybody
was like oh my god and it was this mix
of emotion sure you know it's like oh my
god i'm in the presence of greatness
as well as oh my god you're a dick yeah
you wrote that on my ball like i gotta
and we made him we got the cleaning
products we made him go back in there
and scrub it off good yeah good
citizen's arrest with a scrub daddy with
a scrub daddy yeah yeah so vaginal if
you're listening and we know that you
are
gotcha
what do you think val janel does now
what kind of job does he think it's it's
it's it's it's on the spectrum it's
either like oh definitely homeless yeah
or he's like he's almost like elon musk
i was gonna say like yeah he he made the
mederna
i should have said you might know him
his name's elon musk
what is this now pimp oh you're pulling
up pictures of me this is what i told
you when i and i that's that was that
that is not that's a picture of you
that's graffiti that's a picture of you
that's me
that's when i was a young boy
you look like a ruck rat yeah i look
like a puerto rican lesbian yeah
oh my god
die hard new york giants from wearing a
dion sanders jersey with a nameplate
that says chris with a size that's that
jersey wouldn't fit me now i was 13
years old at my aunt jeanette's house
you you look like
left eye lopez yeah
you look like you're in dlc
yeah you walked around like that open
that was christmas that's how i showed
up to christmas day
by my dad
no it's not my mom that's your sunday
best this is when my mother this kid my
mother could not stand this kid was bad
news yeah look at this
that's the kid it was like cookies are
going on my turkey yeah oh 100
100
i used to walk we used to drive around
one of my friends had a car you know i
was maybe 12 13 years old one of my the
older kid had a car that's that's the
good part about soldiers there's a train
that comes by every 45 minutes it's a
great it's the best place for a comedy
show in the country because right in the
middle of stories you'll get a
cargo train
yeah that's awesome yeah i know when i
made her write i was like this can't be
it yeah i mean and i was like it's just
a train
yeah this guy's the coolest actually
this is probably one of the coolest
shows i've done in a long time this
place is awesome shout out soldiers
shout out seoul joe thank you for having
us this is great yeah to create
something like this i really appreciate
it should i yell can you hear me
i love it it'd be great if like the
train was like two miles long it is
it's obnoxiously long i performed here
in january and i was like ha ha that's
crazy and then it got to the point where
i was like joel why the [ __ ] did you put
a comedy club right it's a 17-hour train
this was the tunnel he just turned it
left yeah but what um no but like is it
are people getting off here though no
it's like a cargo it's taking it's
taking i mean besides me and you later
no no no no
are people getting on and off right here
right now no oh so it's a just it's a
this i know i think it's like a phrase
it's a defunct station no i don't think
no it's not a station it's the tracks
this is no no joel put this tent up it's
not a train station
this is a this is a lot oh we're not at
a train station no joel bought this from
home depot
don't set this up i just i have a vision
in my head of joel joel opening a
cardboard box with a razor blade and
then pulling this out with the
instructions like ikea
just be like oh [ __ ] i need a hand
how insane with that that was my that
train was fantastically long that was a
long train yeah
[Applause]
what
oh it's still going
yeah it's still going
wow what
it's a freight train they're saying oh
it's a freight train which means it
carries goods and services might yeah it
carries freights what do you think that
train had on it
uh sex workers sex workers
um i think it had um i think it probably
had shipments of hellofresh um
[Laughter]
probably had one that at least one full
of blue chew one full of blue chew um
what does a freight train do a freight
train cargo train or goods train is a
group of freight cars or goods wagons
hauled by one or more locomotives on a
railway transporting cargo all or some
of the way between the shipper and the
intended destination as part of this
just sounded almost it all of a sudden
became a second grade classroom yes
locomotive oh because i thought i saw a
station though where the tracks off you
might have
you're on the opposite you're on the
other side of the tracks now babe yeah
what's this what's this body of water
here
this kokoiko river what
no i know it's a river right i know it's
a river
i wasn't like i wasn't like does anyone
know if that's an ocean that guy is
wearing a work outfit is that guy that
just got up and ran into a seat looks
like he's doing a shift and left his
shift he's wearing yeah you at the blue
shirt are you are you is that your work
outfit
you just got done golfing oh it looks
like you're working like best buy or
something and you're like i'm gonna go
off for lunch what's up geek squad
is that still a thing
i don't know i used to go to best buy
every tuesday because that's when they
released the dvds yes when i was heavy
into dvds and i used to go and buy
spend like 20 bucks a dvd and go there
every i just look forward to it i
haven't been to a best buy in a decade
does it still hold up do people still go
to best buy
yeah
all right this guy in the back oh what
do you work for best buy he's got his
arms up why do you work for his arms up
for best buy okay i um
listen
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month what are you doing
yeah i mean what are you doing you're
being silly do that anymore why carry
the credit balance you're already
carrying so much stress and anxiety and
everything else you don't need a credit
balance to add on top of
everything so upstart
upstart is a company it's a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online you don't want
to go to freaking johnny on the corner
and pay all hard cash and then you don't
pay him back and you get your freaking
knee caps broken because then when you
got to go to better help and it's a
whole thing
so it's a story we've heard much too
yeah too much too many times yeah it's
just paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest rates uh
funding your personal expenses over half
a million people have used upstart uh
they know you're more than just a credit
score and uh they are expanding access
to affordable credit yes five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
uh up front for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars fifty
thousand big ones and if you go to
upstart find out how upstart colonial
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you okay
upstart.com hey babe loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
providing your loan application go to
upstart.com
hey babe
listen
hello hello
fresh i'll talk about it all day long
every single podcast every single
freaking podcast that's what adele was
talking about when she made her famous
song hello hello from the freshers
[Music]
listen fall is busy you know how we you
know cause i listen for me with fall and
i almost get like sacrifice cool i roll
around the pumpkin patches i'm i'm
eating cinnamon everywhere i go i'm in
the leaves oh
i lit literally i'm i want to turn my
back down to a pumpkin patch i love it
my mother gave me a piece of pumpkin
loaf yesterday was fantastic we went to
a pumpkin patch last year didn't we not
we had the grapes no we didn't apple
picking now
yeah but you know what
when we went pump up my first time apple
picking bumble picking
it's it's as the episode goes it's a
it's a pumpkin and an apple right
and here's the thing hello fresh has
apple bread pumpkin plus apple bread
well let's tell a little about hello
fresh so what hellofresh is is it's it's
a it's it's a meal service that saves
you time
you know you spend all this time and
money meal planning i can't do it
anymore hello fresh fig is it all out
for you i use hello fresh my family uses
hellofresh this is one of these ones
that we've been using we love the fall
and i've tried this and sal let me tell
you something i tried this i almost
cannonballed off my roof the pumpkin
cinnamon rolls were the best thing
you've ever had in your life it is
i guarantee you i guarantee you if
hellofresh would have just started
dropping pump
so pumpkin cinnamon rolls and friends
giving ready sides as well as fresh high
quality ingredients that travel from the
farm to your front door in less than a
week sal less than a week pumpkin
cinnamon rolls are my favorite
you get better value hellofresh is over
30 cheaper than shopping at grocery
stores with pre-portioned ingredients
that ensure you won't spend money on
excess food that ends up going in the
trash
and here we go go to
hey babe hellofresh.com
and use the code hey babe 14 for up to
14 free mails including free shipping
that's
hellofresh.com14 and use code heybay14
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping try the pumpkin cinnamon rolls
no i haven't been to a best buy in a
while i i don't think i've been to you
know there's no point to go to stores
anymore you just get everything from
amazon i know but that's going to ruin
the world yeah but it's already the
freight train still going that's a new
one
is it the same one
it's the same one
it never ends
it's is it carrying ever
now it's over is it carrying all the
goods might be carrying all the goods
new jersey field ferris wheel stuck new
jersey first yeah i mean dude it gets
scary now because now when i go on rides
i you know because i'm older i got kids
i get nervous that like the ride's going
to go off the track but i never i never
used to get nervous i vomited uh on a
ferris wheel once all over my friend why
because i i was like it was a
combination of like adrenaline and like
nausea
i said nausea
yeah the game slips out with us once in
a while yeah i just threw it just went
out it just said it was like
second time that was the second time i
threw up on a friend saying nausea is
yeah no i would think you'd say no i
don't know nausea
nausea n-a-s-e-a-u
is it a french word
what did he leave did the frenchman
leave
no
you play you play soccer
no is your shirt the french flag
oh
we're good at geography here
we know the flags
yeah what do we what do we got what do
you mean what are we doing what do you
guys want to talk about i like to talk
no but i like i i want i would like yeah
because you know it's a live pod
what about a couple of questions you
know the fans maybe they had things
because you know sometimes you don't get
to the haybaypodcast gmail.com email i
love that we we keep saying we're going
to start a patreon sure and we haven't
yet yeah one of is there about a couple
of fans have a couple of questions or
things they've wanted to say
that you know
okay yes we got i saw your what's going
on
she's got a beautiful painting can you
please show us your vaccine card before
you step any further
i'm kidding did you did you paint this
yourself oh my goodness what is your
name
tony tony tampa tony
look at that wow
thank you tom how do you have this much
talent
this is amazing
that's amazing
it's not full-blown artistic but it's on
this it's not both artistic but it's
gorgeous
this will hang in the studio for an
episode for sure 100 this is really good
it looks really good
how long have you been painting
how long have you been autistic
really how long did that take
like 20 hours
that took 20 hours
can you hear her on the mic no
is the mic on pimp
oh maybe it is
it's okay you're artistic
you're into the arts uh that took 20
hours at least i don't even i don't keep
track oh my god
very talented did you just know like
since you were a kid that you are
autistic
kind of yeah were your special schools
for your autism i'm sure my parents kind
of wanted to figure it out so they took
me to some doctors does anybody ever try
to tell you that you're
not like the rest of us because of your
autism they did they did and what did
you tell them um our artists are just
like everyone else good yeah good
and honestly
art art and artism is a spectrum because
i could try to draw that and it wouldn't
be as good as you sound a little bit on
you know no um
do you do you sketch it first are you
that but which is why some of the
proportions are off but wow what the the
talented amongst our fans is amazing i
don't even know how to like thank
someone that does that puts all the time
and effort into that we appreciate it so
so much thank you so much
beautiful artist tony thank you tony
thank you so much tony we'll definitely
hang that in there yes
um yeah so we were like maybe we like to
talk we never really get to talk to you
guys in this setting so we got a mic we
would love to have a conversation with
you guys
anyone need advice questions advice
anything like that this guy this guy's
got a question sir wallpaper what up
sorry oh boy what happened to the
wallpaper the wallpaper hanger he went
at zero to 60 right
paper
huh
hanger
you weren't you getting wallpaper done
at your house
yeah and the paper hanger you didn't
finish it off did you get it done
oh okay i didn't know what we were
talking about we're just talking about
the wallpaper in my home where i live
yeah
yeah
did i tell you the story about the guy
who was like find somebody else
well i'll tell you i'll tell you what
happened oh is this where you left this
off on the cliffhanger
it's got bangers
so the guy oh damn it guys
the first show is a learning show
the guy was like so for those of you do
you guys know what she answered
you guys know what john's talking about
i know
yeah the guy was like find somebody else
last minute yeah well i wrote back to
him and i imagine i was like and this
has been hey babe no
um well you weren't gonna do that i
ruined it no it's good it's good it's
good it's fun it's fun
no so i i
i got a price from another person i came
to the house and he measured everything
and i'm like the guy that told me that
you know i'm not going to give him my
business so i got a wreck guy came to
measured everything and then that guy if
you remember he wanted to charge me more
than he said initially i think he said
like 700 bucks then he said 900 and i
was like what's up with that and as soon
as i told him and he's like find
somebody else so i'm like f this guy 900
ralph i'm not paying that the new guy
came does everything says me all right
no problem i can do it for you 1700.
it was double the higher price of the
first guy well i don't need to tell you
what i did next i got right on the phone
with the first guy and i was like i'm a
bit of an [ __ ]
it can be whatever you say it is please
come anyway and he came and did it
anyway let me ask you a question the
original guy back the wallpaper let me
ask you a question sal when you said
when you said to that guy when you said
to the to the wallpaper guy
who you know was was
off charging when you said that to him
did he respond to
i cheetos for the eighth time
did he say that to you yeah yeah he was
a real dick that guy
yeah
nice dude i like you man you look dirty
i'd love to get a [ __ ] bug or a
little like a spy cam in your house and
see how passive aggressive you are with
everyone you live with at all times
pass the salt for the eighth time
let's do one more question can we do one
more
[Applause]
oh you made that somebody made something
or just have a full presentation sure
he's what he's afraid of cats
she said that she said this [ __ ] won't
bite you
okay nice
that's kind of like these colors don't
run right yeah um oh everyone's pointing
to someone over there let's just get
this guy yeah the woman with next to the
van gogh dress nice dress van gogh i
like it
i like it sorry if that offended you sal
oh god you said m m's are a candy bar
which is ridiculous
what do you consider a nerd's rope to be
are they a rope candy are they some
different variety or are they considered
a cake i can't really speak nerds are
candy candy's candy nerds rope is candy
but i stand by this and you was a taste
buddy no you were involved in this
conversation we called you on the phone
okay to get an answer i think that m ms
are classified as a candy bar they're
chocolate they're with the candy bar
they satisfy the same urge
i will
i will turn this dome around right now
please
you don't does anyone here agree with me
that m m's are a candy bar
really
sal i have to well what a way to end
this
show
just disagreeing with each other and
storming off from each other
yes that is taste buds it's not yeah
i don't think it is yeah candy bar
really i still want to be best friends
with you yeah but i think that they're
but that's okay because we can agree to
disagree i'm fine with you believing
it's a candy bar but not a candy bar and
i believe with a candy bar and we could
still get along do you see how that
works
she's good everybody a lifeless this
woman will never like me now that's it i
loved her yeah damn it
all right okay she's got a question
she's saying what she said was when you
dm david blaine how did you feel you
know how what how does that feel as
compared to when you get dm because
she's dmtv
you slid into my dms um
by the way great crowd thank you so much
for bringing the worst painting of me
and for bringing up the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
no um no i don't i don't even i i i how
do i feel about dm as long as they're
normal dms i don't even
if if i got one that like i sent to
david blaine which i was like thank you
for the
by the way is your boyfriend just
hearing right now that you're
literally she's sitting right next to
her boyfriend saying i dm sal
constantly he never wait what's your
name i'll search it and i'll read it out
loud yes
was it recent what what platform was it
recent you read it okay you read it yeah
it's not deviant it can't be bad but by
the way i mean
the boyfriend is not happy right now
this section
yeah that section yeah what can you do
nice you get a pass from me she gets a
passer i'll deal with that you look
excited she'll get a pass for me as long
as he gets to pass the chris you're top
or bottom
top i'll go bottom
yeah give him a pinot grigio and an
ambien yes that's one deal
yeah
no i told david blaine i don't know why
i did this i i was like thank you so
much for the
all the wonderments you provide
it was it was mortifying you know joe
just was at a house the other day david
blaine walked in what and started doing
card tricks to joe
wait a minute i swear to god he he
texted me and he goes i was at a house
last night david blaine walked in and
started doing card tricks
really i said what yeah you know what he
did he came in joe was already there he
walked in he goes pick a card
he just he walked in he said pick a card
joe picks a card he says all right puts
it back in the deck shuffles it he just
walked in he goes to the whole deck and
it's not there he goes look under your
watch joe takes off his watch the card
is folded in his watch under his watch
no way that mother the wonderment oh
wait wait wait and you know what and you
know what joe i
because i i had the thing we're doing a
crossover episode for my backyard bar
wars show next week with joe gotto and i
had he told me this he told me and then
when he said when he opened up the card
it said this has been hey yeah
we love you guys
thank
you share us
tell a friend
you guys are the best we love you much
even you thank you thank you so much
have a good day have a good night thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey